Meditazione guidata dettagliata.
Istruzioni su come praticare Vipassana Bhavana, meditazione dell'insight, così come è stata trasmessa da Mahasi Sayado, maestro birmano.
Prima di tutto dobbiamo sistemare il corpo in una posizione meditativa.
Alcuni siedono su una sedia, altri usano un panchetto, ma la posizione usuale è seduti su un cuscino sul pavimento con una postura a gambe incrociate.
Le mani dovrebbero poggiare sul grembo, preferibilmente la sinistra sulla destra.
qualunque postura voi adottiate dovreste sentirvi comodi sin dall'inizio.
Poi assicuratevi che la spina dorsale sia dritta pur mantenendo la sua naturale curvatura.
E' meglio non appoggiarsi a nulla poiché questo indurrà al sonno.
Ora immaginate un filo di marionetta che parte dalla base della colonna vertebrale e arriva alla sommità del capo e che esso venga delicatamente tirato cosicché si separino tutte le vertebre e ci sia la sensazione di diventare alti e leggeri, una sensazione di energia che scorre lungo la spina dorsale senza tensioni o contrazioni.
e la testa dovrebbe sentirsi equilibrata sopra.
Lasciate che tutto si rilassi da quella colonna centrale.
Qui possiamo aiutarci a rilassarci con dei semplici esercizi.
Prima di tutto, vediamo quanto riusciamo a rilassarci semplicemente dicendo ai muscoli di rilassarsi.
Cominciate dalla sommità del capo.
Scendete lungo la fronte, gli occhi, le guance, la mandibola, il collo, le spalle, le braccia e le mani.
Sentite come tutto diventa più pesante quando la tensione smette di sorreggerli.
Ora tornate al petto.
Rilassatelo.
Scendete lungo il corpo fino allo stomaco.
all'addome, rilassandovi quanto più possibile.
E infine sentite le gambe pesanti sul pavimento.
La tensione superficiale dovrebbe essersi un po' sciolta adesso, anche solo un po', ma potremmo sentire un livello di tensione più profondo, più abituale e quindi non facile da rilassare con un atto di volontà mentale.
Qui possiamo usare una seconda tecnica per la tensione muscolare.
Dove sentite tensione, tendete il più possibile i muscoli di quella zona e rilasciateli lentamente.
Questo è particolarmente utile se avete tensioni al volto.
Arricciate il volto il più possibile, trattenete e rilassate.
Proviamo ancora.
Trattenete...
rilassate va bene va anche bene per il collo e le spalle irrigidite tutta la zona trattenete e rilasciate lentamente provate di nuovo irrigidite tutta la zona il collo le spalle trattenete e rilassate lentamente
Una terza tecnica è la migliore per le tensioni del petto nonostante abbia un effetto su tutto il corpo.
Il respiro controllato.
Fate un respiro lento e profondo.
Riempite i polmoni completamente.
Trattenete il respiro il più a lungo possibile e lasciate andare velocemente l'intera cassa toracica buttando fuori l'aria.
Poi
Per evitare l'iperventilazione, aspettate che sorga naturalmente il respiro successivo.
Adesso facciamo un respiro profondo.
Trattenetelo e lasciatelo andare.
Proviamo di nuovo.
Fate un respiro profondo, trattenetelo e lasciatelo andare.
A questo punto dovreste aver sviluppato un rilassamento profondo.
quindi ora dovremmo trovarci in una posizione favorevole alla meditazione.
La spina dorsale dovrebbe essere energizzata, ma non tesa.
Il resto del corpo dovrebbe sentirsi rilassato, come se si lasciasse andare da questa colonna vertebrale centrale.
E il capo dovrebbe trovarsi in equilibrio, simboleggiando l'equilibrio
tra la vigilanza fisica e il rilassamento.
Adesso vedete per qualche momento se potete sentire questa posizione nel suo insieme e riconoscete le qualità di energia vigile unita ad un rilassamento calmo.
Adesso dobbiamo sviluppare lo stesso senso di vigilanza energica e una calma rilassata nella mente.
E per ottenere questo
Usiamo il respiro.
Mettete la vostra attenzione sull'addome e sentite il movimento del salire e scendere mentre respirate naturalmente.
Tenete conto che questa non è una tecnica di respirazione.
Non bisogna interferire con il respiro.
Potrebbe capitare che il respirare non sia così evidente nell'addome, nel qual caso
Vedete se riuscite a sentire il petto che sale e scende.
Si può anche usare il respiro alle narici, ma per la tecnica Masi è preferibile usare l'addome.
Vedete qual è il più evidente per voi.
Qualunque punto del corpo abbiate scelto, questo è il vostro oggetto primario di osservazione.
Questo significa che userete questo punto per sviluppare una consapevolezza vigile e calma.
Se vi spostate da un punto all'altro, per esempio dal naso all'addome, questo indebolirà la vostra abilità di concentrarvi.
Vale a dire l'abilità di osservare con un'attenzione vigile ma calma, senza che la mente voli via.
Se state guardando il processo del respiro all'addome o al petto, osservate il movimento, l'alzarsi e l'abbassarsi e usate un'etichetta mentale per calmare il processo del pensiero.
Con l'ispirazione notate salire salire e con l'espirazione notate scendere scendere.
Dopo l'espirazione
A volte l'inspirazione parte subito senza pausa, ma quando cominciate a rilassarvi, comincerà ad apparire una pausa.
Potrebbe darsi che ci sia una pausa prima dell'inspirazione, sin dall'inizio.
Qui c'è il pericolo che la mente fugga via dietro a fantasie.
Per evitare che ciò succeda, scegliamo un punto di contatto.
Potrebbe essere la sensazione delle vostre mani sul grembo o la sensazione delle gambe sul pavimento.
Scegliete ciò che è più evidente.
Quindi, man mano che sentite l'addome o il petto che salgono con l'ispirazione, sentite quelle sensazioni.
Osservatele attentamente e puntate la vostra attenzione direttamente lì, notando salire, salire.
Fate lo stesso mentre sentite l'addome o il petto che scendono con l'inspirazione.
Sentite le sensazioni, le sensazioni del movimento.
Osservatela attentamente e notate scendere, scendere.
Se c'è una pausa prima dell'inspirazione, notate un punto di contatto, toccare, toccare.
Assicuratevi, non appena inizia
di ritornare immediatamente all'addome o al petto.
Se vi state concentrando sulle narici, è lo stesso, con la differenza che sarebbe più appropriato usare le etichette mentali dentro-dentro, fuori-fuori, ricordandovi di concentrarvi sulle sensazioni alle narici o al labbro superiore, ogni volta che il passaggio dell'aria si sente più chiaramente.
Tenete presente che non ha importanza quante volte dite l'etichetta mentale.
Una volta potrebbe essere sufficiente.
La cosa importante è prestare attenzione alle sensazioni man mano che sorgono.
La parola stessa ha poca importanza.
È solo un modo semplice e molto efficace di fermare la mente che divaga.
Ciò a cui dovete prestare attenzione sono tutte le sensazioni causate dal processo del respiro.
Ora potreste scoprire che la mente divaga verso pensieri o fantasie.
Quando vi risvegliate, notate semplicemente pensare, pensare, sognare, sognare, una o due volte.
E poi velocemente e con fermezza tornate a osservare le sensazioni del respiro.
ma non dovete essere duri o forzare.
Addestrare la mente è un po' come addestrare un cagnolino a sedersi.
Quando si alza, dovete accarezzarlo gentilmente ma con fermezza.
Se vi arrabbiate e lo colpite, vorrà solo scappar via.
Allora adesso esercitiamo questa meditazione sul respiro per un po', mentre osserviamo e notiamo tutte le sensazioni.
Salire, scendere, toccare.
Se la vostra mente sta divagando, notate cosa sta facendo, sognare, pensare, preoccuparsi e così via, e riportatela dolcemente ma fermamente al respiro.
Se vi sentite assonnati,
mettete più energia nella spina dorsale.
Sedete dritti, ma non tesi.
Questa parte della meditazione ha lo scopo principale di sviluppare la concentrazione.
È normale che passino almeno dieci minuti prima che la mente diventi abbastanza calma, almeno finché l'agitazione più grossolana non se ne sia andata e è riuscita ad osservare l'oggetto, in questo caso il respiro,
in modo abbastanza regolare.
Usiamo il respiro perché è una sensazione neutrale, non ci agita né ci deprime.
Così la mente si ferma e va verso un livello di concentrazione attraverso la calma e la pace.
Questo è diverso dal tipo di concentrazione che otteniamo quando facciamo o vediamo qualcosa di avvincente, come guardare un film o quando dobbiamo fare un lavoro attentamente.
In questi casi il tipo di concentrazione dipende da stimoli esterni, ma la concentrazione che ci serve per l'insight deve sorgere da una mente tranquilla e ferma.
E quando si sviluppa questo tipo di mente tranquilla, concentrata, scopriamo che diventa rilevante un'altra facoltà, la nostra intelligenza intuitiva, pagna.
A volte, quando cercate di ascoltare una radio a onde corte, c'è talmente tanta interferenza che è difficile sentire esattamente quello che viene detto.
Una volta che sparisce il disturbo, tutto diventa chiaro.
E così compagna la nostra intelligenza intuitiva.
Una volta che la mente è calma e concentrata e che cessano le attività del pensare e dell'immaginare,
L'intelligenza intuitiva è in grado di vedere e capire chiaramente cosa succede.
Allora, adesso ciò che dobbiamo fare è sviluppare questa attenzione concentrata, animata dall'intelligenza, satipagna, non solo sul respiro, ma su qualsiasi cosa che entra nel nostro campo di coscienza.
L'esempio che mi piace fare è quello del bird watcher.
si siedano in un nascondiglio, nascosti dagli uccelli che stanno osservando.
In questo modo gli uccelli non sono disturbati e si possono osservare le loro abitudini naturali.
Tutta la conoscenza riguardo all'alimentazione, la nidificazione, l'accoppiamento, eccetera, si ha semplicemente osservando, semplicemente guardando.
Allo stesso modo, l'abilità di essere semplici osservatori
interessate a scoprire la vera natura del nostro corpo, mente e cuore, è la chiave dell'insight spirituale.
Ma questo osservare, sia chiaro, non è un cercare qualcosa.
Non siamo alla ricerca di qualcosa.
Siamo semplici osservatori che non interferiscono, che semplicemente guardano ciò che entra nel loro campo di coscienza.
Semplicemente guardare ciò che sorge nel qui e ora, mentre sta succedendo, senza pensieri a riguardo né domande.
Così cominciamo sviluppando l'attenzione sul respiro.
Dovessimo sentire un suono?
Lo avvertiamo immediatamente, notando sentire, sentire.
Ora,
Provate a cogliere la qualità del suono proprio all'orecchio.
In questo modo tratterremo la mente dal volar via, per così dire, verso l'oggetto, che sia il cinghettio di un uccello o un'auto che passa, ed eviteremo di dare inizio ad un'intera catena di pensieri immaginativi.
Lo stesso vale per un odore.
Notatelo per com'è.
odorare, odorare, proprio lì alle narici.
Se di nuovo con qualsiasi sensazione del corpo, come il prurito o il formicolio, o la sensazione del contatto delle gambe sul pavimento, notate semplicemente prurito, prurito, pesantezza, pesantezza, proprio lì dove si sentono le sensazioni.
immergetevi in esse con l'attenzione.
Poi ci sono sensazioni che sorgono nel corpo, come il caldo e il freddo, la pesantezza e la leggerezza, tutti i tipi di dolore, fastidi e piaceri.
Si può usare una parola particolare come caldo o freddo, laddove appropriato, oppure si può usare una parola generale, come sentire.
Ora è importante non reagire a queste sensazioni, a meno che non siano troppo forti da sopportare.
Ricordatevi che l'etichetta mentale è una tecnica che usiamo per mantenere l'attenzione stabile sull'oggetto.
In altre parole, controlla la facoltà del pensiero, ma l'attenzione stessa dovrebbe penetrare nell'effettiva sensazione.
Poi ci sono sensazioni nel corpo che sorgono da stati d'animo ed emozioni, quelle gradevoli come paura, depressione e senso di colpa, e quelle gradevoli come pigrizia, gioia e amore.
Qui possiamo usare parole specifiche come senso di colpa, amore, ma continuando a sentire pienamente
lo stato d'animo o le emozioni, le sensazioni effettive ovunque si presentino, come nel petto, nello stomaco o nell'addome, persino nella testa.
Infine ci sono pensieri e immagini.
Notateli come pensare o immaginare ed essi finiranno.
Altrimenti vi trascineranno in un sogno d'occhi aperti, a volte per l'intero periodo della meditazione.
e prestate particolare attenzione alla mente giudicante.
È terribile, non va bene, così va bene, è bello, e così via.
Non correggete né interferite con tali pensieri.
Riconosceteli semplicemente e notate «giudicare, giudicare».
Non stiamo cercando di diventare spettatori, coinvolti in tutti i giochi mentali, sostenendo una posizione piuttosto che l'altra.
noi dobbiamo assumere la posizione dell'osservatore, un osservatore obiettivo, semplicemente permettendo a tutti i giochi di dispiegarsi proprio qui davanti ai nostri occhi.
E per tutto il tempo cerchiamo di mantenere quella separazione, quella distanza, quel distacco da qualsiasi cosa accada nel corpo, nella mente e nel cuore.
Noi osserviamo tutti questi eventi psicofisici come qualcosa d'altro, come se appartenessero ad un'altra persona.
In questo modo possiamo investigare obiettivamente.
Così, qualunque cosa venga offerta, una sensazione, un'emozione, un pensiero, solamente osservatela, con attenzione.
Sentitela pienamente, provatela direttamente.
Ora sediamoci e con un interesse acuto guardiamo il flusso dei fenomeni fisici e mentali.
Cominciate sempre con il respiro.
Salire, scendere, toccare.
Se la mente divaga notate cosa stava facendo, sognando, pensando, preoccupandosi e via di seguito e riportatela al respiro fermamente ma dolcemente.
Se c'è pigrizia, energizzate la spina dorsale.
Ristabilite la postura.
Lentamente, molto lentamente, o potreste disturbare la vostra concentrazione.
Notate l'intero movimento.
Raddrizzare, raddrizzare.
Qualche volta c'è molto dolore.
Disturbi e tensioni sorgono nel corpo.
Questo non dipenderà dalla postura, se è corretto.
saranno probabilmente causati da emozioni non risolte o stati mentali che sono stati soppressi e spinti fuori dalla coscienza.
È importante rilassarsi nei loro confronti e sviluppare un'attitudine di interesse.
Questi disturbi, a volte molto fastidiosi, potrebbero continuare per la durata di un'intera seduta e per molte sedute finché non si risolvono.
Potrebbe essere che la ragione sottostante, come un'emozione, non si manifesti.
Solo quando il disturbo sarà passato indicherà che la guarigione è avvenuta.
Dobbiamo sviluppare pazienza per sopportare questo tipo di cosa e usare l'opportunità di vedere il dolore come dolore, solo sensazione, e separare la sofferenza, che è l'avversione o la paura che noi sentiamo.
Prendiamo entrambe le parti, le sensazioni dolorose e le attitudini mentali come oggetti da notare, osservare e capire.
Così continuate a notare, continuate a osservare, mantenendo un'attenzione acuta.
Se vi perdete, cominciate di nuovo dal respiro, la vostra casa base e ancora.
Cominciate sempre dal respiro, salire, scendere, toccare.
Se la mente divaga, riportatela fermamente ma dolcemente all'oggetto primario, il respiro.
Se c'è stanchezza o intorpidimento, fate salire l'energia su per la spina dorsale sedendovi dritti, ma non tesi, ricordate.
Siate particolarmente attenti all'attenzione intorno alle spalle, collo e mandibola.
Ed eccoci seduti dentro noi stessi, per così dire, guardando un film interno.
Il corpo, la mente e il cuore si mettono in mostra proprio come vogliono.
Noi non interferiamo.
È un processo naturale di rivelazione.
Con il tempo potrebbero sorgere dall'inconscio molte cose che sono state soppresse a lungo.
Si riveleranno quando è il momento giusto e quando saremo pronti ad accettarle.
In questo modo la meditazione dell'insight effettua una psicoterapia.
Anche i ricordi traumatici dolorosi dell'infanzia saranno con il tempo rimossi dal sistema e con essi tutte le ossessioni e le tensioni che hanno causato.
Tutto ciò che dobbiamo fare per raggiungere questa purificazione del cuore è rimanere fermi nella nostra postazione di osservazione.
Ora, anche se la nostra purificazione psicologica accadrà naturalmente, non è questo l'obiettivo della meditazione.
Lo scopo della nostra pratica è di andare ai livelli più profondi per vedere in primo luogo perché sorge la sofferenza.
Una modalità è di notare la relazione che abbiamo con qualunque cosa stiamo osservando.
La mente salta continuamente dall'attrazione alla repulsione,
dal volere ciò che le piace al non volere ciò che non le piace.
Questo tipo di coinvolgimento è semplicemente un modo in cui noi cerchiamo di trovare la felicità negli stati piacevoli e sfuggire all'infelicità scappando dagli stati spiacevoli.
Questa costante oscillazione, questo rimbalzare dall'avidità alla versione di nuova avidità, questo è ciò che, nella seconda nobile verità, il Buddha ha detto essere la causa della nostra insoddisfazione.
Così, man mano che sorgono oggetti piacevoli e spiacevoli, noi dobbiamo notare attentamente questa reazione secondaria dell'afferrarli e del respingerli.
qualche volta allontanandoci con paura la sorella gemella dell'avversione.
In questo modo questa reazione si raffredderà e potrebbe anche esaurirsi e noi sperimenteremo una mente equanime profondamente soddisfacente.
A sua volta questo ci permetterà di indagare più profondamente nelle cause della sofferenza.
Allora lasciate che tutto quel dolore e piacere venga alla superficie e si esprima.
Osservate la reazione, l'afferrare, l'avversione, la paura.
Desiderio, desiderio, avversione, avversione, paura, paura.
Cominciate nuovamente con il respiro.
Salire, scendere, toccare.
se la mente divaga notate cosa stava facendo e ristabilite la vostra concentrazione sul respiro se siete assonnati sedetevi dritti e fate salire l'energia lungo la spina dorsale
Mentre cominciate ad approfondire la vostra consapevolezza di tutti i fenomeni che sorgono nel vostro corpo, mente e cuore, diventerete sempre più consapevoli di ciò che il Buddha chiamò le tre caratteristiche dell'esistenza.
La prima è il fatto della transitorietà.
Tutto sorge e svanisce.
La seconda è il difficile insegnamento del non-sè.
Mentre guardate tutti questi fenomeni fisici e mentali, noterete che sorgono per proprio conto, non c'è nessuno che li controlla.
Hanno una loro vita propria, una loro propria energia.
A volte il corpo, la mente e il cuore potrebbero sembrare distanti, un'altra cosa.
Prima abbiamo parlato delle mie sensazioni, dei miei pensieri, delle mie emozioni.
Ma adesso ci troviamo a indicarli, per così dire, attraverso la tecnica dell'annotare.
C'è una sensazione, c'è un pensiero, c'è un'emozione.
Ci stiamo lentamente spostando da una relazione di identità e di possesso.
Io sto vedendo.
Io sono ciò che penso.
Io sono ciò che sento.
Io ho un corpo.
Io ho una mente.
Io ho un cuore.
Invece ci stiamo avvicinando verso una posizione di distacco.
Questo è l'inizio dell'esperienza del non-sé.
Noi scopriamo che l'organismo psicopatologico che noi chiamiamo me non costituisce nulla di sostanziale.
è costituito da tante parti che lavorano all'unisono, proprio come un'automobile, ma non c'è un nucleo centrale, non esiste per sostanza.
Terzo punto, come abbiamo notato, ogni volta che entriamo in una relazione di attaccamento, desiderio o avversione al corpo, alla mente o al cuore, l'identità è possesso e consegue la sofferenza.
Questa è la caratteristica dell'insoddisfazione.
Dovremmo sviluppare un atteggiamento nei confronti del corpo, della mente e del cuore, come di uno che affitta una casa, non che la possiede.
È l'osservazione di queste tre caratteristiche di transitorietà, insostanzialità e insoddisfazione che porta agli insight spirituali.
che liberano la coscienza dalle sue illusioni e porta alla liberazione da tutta la sofferenza.
Ed è questa pratica di Vipassana lo strumento che utilizziamo.
Questa nuda attenzione, semplicemente osservando tutto ciò che sorge e passa.
Questa consapevolezza senza scelta, che non controlla né manipola.
Questa osservazione imparziale, che non mette in discussione né giudica.
questa introspezione intuitiva, sperimentando pienamente ogni fenomeno così come è veramente.
Questa è la facoltà della consapevolezza intuitiva, satipagna, proprio la facoltà che porterà con il tempo alla realizzazione del Nibbana.
Il non nato, il non divenuto, il non creato, l'incondizionato,
Tutto ciò che dobbiamo fare è osservare, solo osservare, qualunque cosa sorga, mentre sorge e passa.
Ricominciate con il respiro, salire, scendere, toccare.
Durante la vita quotidiana sedersi così anche solo per qualche momento, abbastanza per ristabilire un'attenzione calma e vigile, impedirà alle nostre emozioni di avere un effetto valanga.
Minerale cause dello stress.
15 minuti potrebbero essere sufficienti per ristabilire il nostro centro.
Con l'esercizio, questo può diventare uno stato mentale regolare, invece di qualcosa che avviene solo in determinate condizioni.
Questo cuore calmo e questa mente vigile sono lo stato in cui dovremo trovarci sempre, anche sotto stress.
È all'interno di questo ambiente interno che questa consapevolezza intuitiva, satipagna, può operare.
Altrimenti si perde, sommersa e controllata da pensieri ed emozioni che sfuggono al controllo.
Dovremmo costantemente sforzarci di riguadagnare e mantenere questa posizione interiore.
Questo è vivere in piena coscienza.
In questo modo, la pratica di vipassana, la meditazione dell'insight,
penetrerà in ogni momento della nostra vita e noi saremo premiati con grandi benefici.
Ora, quando giungete alla fine di un periodo di meditazione, non saltatene fuori, ma uscitene lentamente.
Prima aprite gli occhi, fate entrare la luce, delicatamente dondolatevi da una parte all'altra e alzatevi lentamente e con consapevolezza
In questo modo potrete mantenere la vostra consapevolezza intuitiva, satipagna.
Possiate essere in buona salute.
Possiate essere felici.
Possiate presto essere liberi da tutta la vostra sofferenza.
Possiate sperimentare la pace e beatitudine del Nipana.